surprisingly the answer is that car
would be logged let's examine why the
Amy object doesn't have a local dot
constructor property but Amy does
delegate to van dot prototype van dot
prototype is a brand new object that has
been set up to delegate to card a
prototype that brand new object does not
have its own dock constructor property
much like any object coming out of
object create should not at best it is
an object that delegates to an object
that has its own dot constructor
property car dot prototype has a doc
constructor property because every
single dot prototype object that comes
for free with the function when it's
created is given one of these dot
constructor properties pointing back to
the original function